Schulter runter und jetzt zurück eins
zwei
eins zwei Schatz und zurück eins zwei
es bleibt wirklich gut im Kopf
vielleicht nächste Staffel ihr könnt
gerne mal anfangen mit paluten würde ich
das gerne machen einfach so
ruf jetzt an unter folgender Nummer wir
bleiben in der Bauchbinde ein ich weiß
auch nicht mehr sonst kommt okay
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen ins Welt hallo
ich bin in Sallys Welt
mein Lieblingsfreund freddy ist wieder
da und wir bereiten heute drei geniale
Rezepte zu drei ich weiß gar nicht
aussprechen aber es sind drei so
tiktok-rezepte
vertical Rezepte vertical
funktioniert
ja
ich verstehe die Plattform ich habe noch
ein paar Tipps und Tricks für dich
mitgebracht Hashtags das neue Ding
wow wir hatten auf Instagram gerade so
ein Meeting und da hieß es ich würde
keine Sekunde der Welt für Hashtags
verbrauchen deswegen benutzt man ja auch
Apps dafür die das Generieren und
scouten welche gut funktionieren ich
benutze auch keine Hashtags jeder sagt
was andere egal wir fangen jetzt mal an
mit einem schönen Rezept und zwar wird
es ein Schokoladenkuchen
[Musik]
den könnt ihr gerne auch vegan
herstellen wenn ihr vegane Milch also
Hafer Soja Mandelmilch etc nehmt oder
auch ganz klassisch mit normaler Milch
und am besten nimmt man danach entweder
eine Silikonform oder wenn man keine
Silikonform hat kann man auch eine
ganz normale nehmen
ausnehmen oder ihr nehmt eine andere
Form liegt Frischhaltefolie rein geht
auch also ihr braucht nicht unbedingt
das Silikonform und jetzt dafür bin ich
da oder ihr nimmt einfach eine Form aus
Sallys Shop da gibt's nämlich einiges an
Formen und auch welche die sehen aus wie
Murat ja dafür verwenden wir 600 g Mehl
60 g Zucker eine Prise Salz 30 g Kakao
etwas Tonka Paste eine Tüte und 150
Gramm
fertig super dann kann man jetzt
eigentlich schon an Topf den nehmen wir
kurz daher was ist das wohl das ist eine
Antirutschmatte aber nur für Induktion
geeignet damit Töpfern nicht rutschen
und dein Herd nicht zerkratzt weil oft
ist du auf dem Herz und wenn du jetzt
drin rührst dann wackelt der Topf so
springen oder irgendwas drunter ist
Gewürze zerkratzt das jetzt hast du
diese Antirutsch
t
jetzt kannst du jetzt musst du den Topf
nicht mehr halten und kannst mit einer
Hand rühren uns andere in die in der
anderen dann kannst du Handy nehmen oder
so
in meiner App Störung
wir gehen jetzt einfach alle Zutaten
rein bis auf die Schokolade die kommt
nicht rein aber Kakao Zucker
weil es kurz zur Schokolade passt
am Handy ach so dann hier so genau
wirklich Veggie und oder vegan
wenn es Klümpchen frei ist kommt die
restliche Milch dazu ist eigentlich muss
man sagen wie so eine Art Pudding ohne
Stärke stattdessen mit agar-agern
[Musik]
das sieht anfangs immer aus als wird
sich nicht verbinden
Abzug an damit das überschüssige Pulver
abgesaugt wird oder warum machen wir das
oder war das jetzt aus Versehen ach so
okay ich dachte ich habe wieder einen
Trick verpasst oder so
super sieht es aus
also ich habe jetzt die Firma mit Wasser
ausgespült ich glaube das hilft beim
rausstürzen ich glaube es geht auch ohne
aber ich habe ein bisschen Angst
trotzdem immer mit Wasser geht
und wenn man nicht lesen kann dann
schaut man uns Videos richtig
und stummes Videos natürlich weil er
alles exakt genauso macht wie ich denn
er hat gut gelernt und gut aufgebaut
genau ich teste das dann bei Restaurants
ob die das genauso machen wie
schon ja es wird es kommt jetzt gleich
was ich wollte ein bisschen weniger ein
bisschen weniger Action reingeben
[Musik]
schön nach Schoki
zum Glück habe ich die rutschfeste Matte
dass ich jetzt an mein Handy gehen kann
warte
[Musik]
schönes
ja ich gehe immer gerne auf achs.com und
wir Smalltalk
okay bist du bereit zehn
lustige Fragen fürs erste Date
ich mache es ich mache die nächste Seite
aus mit so unangenehm mein Bruder
gleiche durchläuft ist ein bisschen
schwierig
oh Gott aber zum Glück habe ansonsten
alles über meiner äh in meinem
Induktionsherd wäre
writing with the black or blue Pen Max
lieber blau schwarzen Schiff beim
Notizen schreiben
blau
auch blau finde ich gut wie findest du
würdest du lieber auf dem Land oder in
der Stadt leben
auch Land deswegen ziehen wir aus Köln
Weg do you consider oh Gott Alter ist
das heißt oh Gott das heißt Sallys es
kocht über glaube ich Sallys Koch glaub
über oh Gott ich habe kein ich habe
keine Haut an den Fingern oh Gott man
muss ja die Blasen daraus machen
kann und parallel moderieren kann die
Gäste unterhalten was ist dein
Sternzeichen
meinte Steinbock passt sehr gut
zueinander ich habe ja immer meine
Astrologie
Aszendenten habe ich immer dabei
morgen Sternzeichen für uns alle ja sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
was ist ein meistgenutztes emoji
2 Minuten geschafft
[Applaus]
das Herz was ist deins
warum bist du aus der Puste
dass ich viele Sachen jetzt nicht gesagt
haben
[Gelächter]
ich glaube die Augen die so machen
[Musik]
oder nee die betenden Hände
geschickt so ja ich hoffe bei dir wird
alles wieder gut und dann halt so ein
bisschen unangenehm bei den ganzen
Leuten
okay also durch das wunderbar gekocht
zwei Minuten lang sprudeln es wird auch
wunderbar geklappt haben und jetzt könnt
ihr hier die Kuvertüre reingeben und sie
schmelzen lassen ich glaube tatsächlich
das ist so warm dass mein Blutkreislauf
jetzt hier erhitzt im Arm und dann über
den Rest des Körpers gibt von hier Hitze
die aufsteigt jetzt in den Rest meines
Körpers ja du machst so Spaß du
veräppeln
so sind wir hier aber sieht gut aus
einfach mal probieren dürfen wir schon
vegan schöne Löffel
wie wäre das eigentlich mal mit dir und
Japan
weil die essen ja auch ganz viel Ruhe
Eier da das wäre glaube ich dann das
werden lustiges Video es gibt aber ich
bin mir sicher dass bei den Japanern
nicht stinken nee ich glaube auch die
sind so sauber und so die sind so viele
geraden mit allem die haben so eine
krasse Koch und Backkunst und so eine
Patisserie ich finde die japanische
Küche ist eigentlich für mich so die
höchste Küche der Welt
ja ich fahre dann Auto ich habe Angst
vorm Fliegen
ich finde wir sollten mal die japanische
Küche entdecken vielleicht nicht gerade
zur Kirschblütenzeit ich glaube da sind
viele Menschen
ne sondern welche außerhalb aber die
Kirschblütenzeit ist so schön deswegen
weiß ich jetzt auch nicht
fragen ob wir vorbeikommen
die kriegen ne smalltal
[Musik]
herzlichen Glückwunsch
greetings from the Germany to the Japan
we from the baking and cooking sight
wish lot of greetings to the pewdiepie
child please don't call im Steffen thank
you
und dann geben wir es in Kühlschrank und
lassen es fest werden und hoffen dass
daraus sitzen schöner Kuchen entsteht oh
mein Gott die Füllmenge passt fast
perfekt okay zu wenig wie lange dauert
bis der dann fertig ist schon ein paar
Stunden im Kühlschrank ein paar Stunden
im Kühlschrank aber in der Zwischenzeit
machen wir einfach noch ein anderes
Rezept oder das finde ich sehr gut denn
es gibt ja noch zwei Stück bei dir
[Musik]
Brot mit Joghurt
vor zwei Jahren war ich das erste Mal
hier seitdem hat sich viel verändert
heute treffen wir ein Unternehmerin aus
Baden-Württemberg die mit Katzen spricht
die Katze ist gelernt hat
und auch sie lernen mit Katzen zu
sprechen gehen Sie jetzt aufs Handys
Katzenwelt Punkt BW das Land
Baden-Württemberg unterstützt diese
Unternehmerin
[Musik]
wirklich das in diesem Haushalt solche
Worte untertitelt werden muss ich ja
ganz ehrlich sagen
[Musik]
also Rezept Nr 2 dafür nehmen wir 10 g
Hefe oder 20 g Trockenhefe einen
Teelöffel Zucker 290 g Wasser 500 g Mehl
ich habe hier das 550er Mehl und einen
Teelöffel Salz und hier gibt es einfach
alle Zutaten in die Rührschüssel
und knetet einen lockeren Hefeteig
daraus
Backanfänger mache ich erst die
flüssigen Zutaten rein und vermischt
dann die trockenen bevor ich sie
reingebe zusammen ja wir machen so hefe
Zucker Wasser sind die besten Freunde
hefe Zucker und Wasser lieben sich
Hefe Fett und Salz lieben sich nicht
deswegen immer als verständiger Mehl
dazwischen
und Salz dann zum Schluss und Fett auch
wenn Fett dazu käme ja
magst du gerne Hefeteig ich liebe Hefe
natürlich nicht jetzt vielleicht schon
jetzt weißt du die Reihenfolge
und egal ob per Hand oder mit der
Maschine
einfach 10 Minuten lang geschmeidig
kneten
ja und danach fahren wir daraus eine
Kugel lassen ihn aufgehen und wenn er
aufgegangen ist
gar kein Problem ich habe aber dafür
viel gelernt
gerne
[Musik]
die muss man nur so kneten
jetzt aufgehen lassen
macht alles geschmeidig
manchmal nehme ich auch so für die Türen
für Scharniere 40
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
okay Teig ist fertig
und jetzt
verstehe aber ich bin auch ein
schlechter Bäcker ja man macht ja immer
man lässt es immer aufgehenden Hefeteig
und danach quatscht man den wieder so
platt ja da geht ja wieder auf die Hefe
Arbeit das ist in meiner Welt Quiche
quatschi sage ich euch genauso
das machen wir jetzt schon mal warm die
Platte man muss auf Stufe siebeneinhalb
7,5 Schritte habt sechs ja und ich würde
sagen wir machen einfach kleine hast du
halbe Schritte bei Dir ja nicht alle
aber
das heißt immer wenn ihr nur sieben oder
acht könnt macht ihr immer runter nehmen
alle paar Minuten
okay und dann einfach ein Stückchen und
dann und dann
also komm probieren wir jetzt hier mal
so nimmst zwei Stück immer so ein
bisschen mit dem Finger nach unten
ich habe aber andere Finger als du weißt
du was es sagt jetzt
in closer von denen
Glas
jetzt mache ich lieber auf der
Oberfläche als hier ne ich habe keine
Lust hier der Oberfläche zu verkratzen
nö da passiert nichts
ich nehme die linke Hand die war
anscheinend gut
aber das ganz normal
acht Stück zwei vier
übertrieben super gut vier
vier acht Stück ne ja okay dann einmal
so
16 Stücke geteilt
Kuchenstücke Kuchen
so noch mal
vor cool manche tiktok Brot Leute sind
jetzt sehr stolz auf mich die mir so
richtig stolz bist du auch eine tiktok
brotfrau nein Brot
der sehr gut bitte Moment sehr geil
macht er das so richtig mit
Sauerteigführung alles
wenn dann richtig ne
und jetzt haben wir hier den Teig
drücken wir flach
immer so
einmal so warte mal ich habe 5 mm ich
glaube wir machen 3 mm drauf dann ist
bisschen dünner und dann können Sie in
der Pfanne schön ausbacken und dann
werden sie dick ne okay bestreichen wir
die noch mit Öl oder sowas ganz trocken
in der Pfanne ausgewachsen okay
du weiter aus und ich hole die drei
Millimeter
3 mm
[Musik]
ohne Fett wenn jetzt eine Gusseisen aber
eine beschichtete Pfanne geht auch nie
ein bisschen dünner ach egal komm das
wird die Stunde Version
nein ich verstehe und dann wenn man das
so noch ein paar coole Smalltalk Fragen
machen
natürlich also bist du bereit ja hast du
einen groben Themenbereich wo du denn
gerne hin wollen würdest mit den
Smalltalk Fragen okay überhaupt nicht
nee ähm ich habe nur okay was war deine
erste Arbeitsstelle 100 mal jetzt hier
behandelt worden okay wir gehen weiter
oh ich habe bei der Arbeiterwohlfahrt
gearbeitet Essen auf Rädern ich habe
Essen ausgeteilt im alten Menschen
rumgefahren und eigentlich war es auch
immer so mein Papa hat nämlich mir keine
Nebenjobs erlaubt konzentriere dich auf
die Schule deswegen durfte keine Zeitung
austragen und hier und da war ich aber
18 und habe den Job gekriegt bei der AWO
Essen auf Rede und dann hat er gesagt
das kann ich mache das Auto fahre
[Musik]
ich glaube ja
Praktikum dazu
ist ein Job nicht immer wenn man was
verdient
ja dann Youtuber
also man kann es ehrlich da muss es auch
nicht irgendwie so tun was empfie
hlst du trotzdem gute wohltätige Zwecke
in freiwilliges soziales Jahr ist auch
immer tatsächlich sehr wichtig ansonsten
haben wir damals immer Studium
Ausbildung eher inzwischen eher
Ausbildung wenn es sein muss ein Studium
es ist nicht schlecht ist aber ihr habt
wirklich auch riesige Möglichkeiten im
Markt momentan wenn ihr eine gute
Ausbildung macht und werdet immer einen
Job haben und ihr könnt auch was ja
gerade im Handwerk hast du meine
berühmte Person getroffen
wer ist jemand den du wirklich
bewunderst du okay du was liest du
gerade
was der beste Rat den du je gehört hast
dass du interessant bei dir glaube ich
beste
das ist meiner ist viel viel
analytischer das ist ja richtig
schrecklich ich habe
beobachten Wissen schaffen
und machen so uns runter zu brechen das
sind so die drei steps sammelst du was
außer Katzen
[Musik]
nee ich bin eigentlich eher so der
ausmiste Typ also ich hatte mal eine
Sammler Krankheit ich habe
Zuckerstreusel gesammelt ich hatte so
einen zweimal ein Meter Schrank mit
Zuckerstreusel aber das habe ich jetzt
hinter mir die Zeit ist vorbei
Zuckerstreusel ja dann hatte ich meine
Zeit lang Nagellacks habe ich auch immer
nix ich bin der Typ du ähm Videospiele
Alter
aber ist mir jetzt auch zur Last
gefallen als ich das ganze mal umziehen
lassen das waren vier Wochen voller
Schmerzen auf jeden Fall naja 2500 Stück
dumm keine Zeit mehr für
also ich habe eine Liste mit 100 Stück
vorbereitet falls ich weiß nicht wie
lange wie lange du möchtest aber ich
kann dir gerne ein paar Highlights
raussuchen warte warte dann machen wir
jetzt die Brötchen fertig und dann
machen wir gleich weiter
oder kommen eine hau noch eine raus
das kannst du am besten
[Gelächter]
tanzen richtig denn ihr könnt jetzt
anrufen und da folgende eingeblendete
Nummer fürs Handy bei Let's Dance
einfach mal so auch wenn es gerade hat
kein Let's Dance ist einfach mal anrufen
vielleicht mal mit den Leuten reden die
sitzen da ja den ganzen Tag
[Musik]
sieht super aus
habt gebacken du kannst auch dönerbrote
machen
danke ich werde zu Lukas bedeuten
okay also die Brote sind gemacht die
stellen wir kurz zur Seite und jetzt
zeige ich dir mal was Atome ist okay
und falls ihr noch eine andere Beilage
oder einen Dip sucht bei stormi dem
sturmi habe ich das Rezept gegeben für
den allerbesten den weltbesten käsigsten
Käse der Welt den wir oft am Wochenende
für die Kinder aufzubereiten und es ist
der Hammer ist er der Hammer
man würde sagen da wo ich herkomme ein
lekoopert also ihr könnt Joghurt Dip
machen oder also Achtung machen oder ihr
könnt Käse die machen einfach beides
oder Männer
nur um Zitronen
das sind zitronenkaffee das alles wird
weiß ich nichts machen
bis unter einer zitronenwiese setzen
[Musik]
Hühner nicht aber dann machen ja gerne
ich habe auch gerade dran gedacht als
wir da in Florida Paris wo waren wir
noch am Nordpol oh das war schön okay
unser Törtchen ist fest und da stelle
ich jetzt direkt rein
und wir müssen stürzen und jetzt in der
Silikonform kann man einfach so machen
und dann knibbeln ich
hoffe nicht probiert
[Musik]
die kleine Büroklammer auf dem gibt's
gleich Tipps
süß
ist wirklich sehr süß jetzt können wir
hier einfach Kakao drüber geben ich habe
da so einen Trick guck mal das Reis drin
dann kommt nämlich nicht zu viel Kakao
auf einmal raus
eine schöne matte Oberfläche oder man
lässt sich glänzend
glänzend war fast schöner und falls ihr
natürlich
war glänzend
tatsächlich ein bisschen matt ist immer
gut sage ich ein bisschen matt ist immer
gut
oder
sieht zwar ein bisschen aus wie so ein
mies operierter
gerne wohl
okay
so an am Rand okay
beide auf einer Seite oder zwei Seiten
kommen jeder auf seiner Seite eins zwei
drei
[Musik]
okay
du bist viel mutiger als ich
weiß wofür das richtig gut ist nochmals
Aufstrich fürs Brot
aber ist eine spannende Konsistenz aber
das auch muss man ja dazu sagen komplett
vegan mit
Hafermilch ja
tatsächlich bin ich mir so kritisch
ich fände es jetzt eher als Pudding
besser also statt Agar-Agar einfach ganz
normal Stärke so wie man halt Pudding
macht weil Pudding kannst du auch
stürzen Pudding wird auch fest und ich
finde Pudding ist nicht in der
Konsistenz so eklig wie das hier
konsistenzmäßig auf jeden Fall
Minuspunkt schon wieder zugeschmacklich
lecker geschmacklich lecker weil lecker
geschmacklich ist ja auch wie so eine
Art Pudding einfach
da muss ich diesen Trend aus dem
Internet leider leider
wir machen so Punkte Punktesystem ne
okay und jetzt kommt die Wertung der
Fachjury
ihre Wertung bitte
von eins bis zehn
okay also
[Musik]
Farbe zurück zum Herz wow das ist sehr
lecker gewesen aber auch nicht so lecker
wie es hätte sein können aber es lag
auch am Agar Agar ich bin bei einer
sechs von zehn
ja hervorragend
so jetzt machen wir mal hier Atom Atom
ist ein wollte ich sagen Atom ist ein
eine Vorspeise eigentlich ein Messer und
zwar nimmt man dafür stichfesten Joghurt
so ein richtig schönen
Sahnejoghurt das heißt stichfester
Joghurt dass der wenn du mit Messer
nimmst größte Messer genau Tatort
Frankfurt stichfest
und du hast hier so kleine Chilis die
sind tatsächlich aus meinem Garten
getrocknet aber du hast Chilis im Garten
ja warum
oh Gott das war genau dieser Abend oh je
das sind magische Schmerzen die kommen
langsam wieder zurück nee gar kein
Problem ist lecker habe ich gesagt doch
ganz gut guck mal und hier verträgst du
Schärfe nicht so nicht schaffe sehr gut
aber was überhaupt was essen ja mach mal
obwohl doch du kannst auch sehr viel
essen ne aber ich kann auch gut scharf
ist nicht allem gehen wir mal zusammen
schlafen
nicht drei Cocktails die ballern sondern
drei Gerichte die ballern
so okay
die haben wir jetzt hier die lassen wir
einweichen weil die sind getrocknet und
wir wollen sie gleich aber noch anbraten
dass sie nicht verbrennen
dass die Chilis nicht verbrennen müssen
Sie ein bisschen weich gemacht werden
mit kochendem Wasser stell mal kurz zur
Seite
mach ruhig rein gar kein Problem alles
gut einer der zahlreichen Mitarbeiter in
diesem Hause wir machen kleine
Vorstellung
der macht hier was machst du hier kommt
jetzt Mikrofon rein was machst du hier
bist dein Job genommen
das sehr gut also man sieht
jetzt los
[Musik]
Test funktioniert das Produkt so auch
ohne mit Schale geht weil
knoblauchschäler
hey moment mal du kannst dich
Joghurt von uns
[Gelächter]
alles verrühren jetzt wohl
noch mal weiter
wichtig abschmecken weil ansonsten
schmeckt nicht ja so dann nehmen wir die
Chilis hier raus und trocknen sie so ein
bisschen
Leute mit Pranken sieht ein bisschen aus
wie Stracciatella ne einfach so am Ende
Gefrierfach und dann einfach mal in so
ein kleines Hörnchen rein und dann sagen
hey Leute team meeting wir haben
Stracciatella Eis gemacht und alle so
boah und dann alles so
Chilis abtrocknen und du kannst schon
mal Olivenöl in dem Fenster die die
nicht kaputt geht die Flasche
oh das habe ich gesehen hier rein
in die kleine Emaille Geschichte dann
mache ich dann mal das was am besten
kann immer noch ein bisschen Gegenstände
davor stellen so okay weil die kann man
ja immer auf Induktion noch warm machen
ne
dann kannst du hier Moment nicht zu hoch
mach ruhig ein bisschen mehr
und die Chilis einfach kurz fein
schneiden
abgemacht super also wir nehmen die
Chilis schneiden Sie
und das Öl müssen wir ein bisschen
runterstellen das wird zu heiß sonst
verbrennen die Chilis und dann braten
wir die an oh weißt du was ich vergessen
habe ein bisschen Paprikapulver unten in
der Schublade
so
jetzt kommen die da rein
haha ich habe es gefunden
zweieinhalb Jahre habe ich gebraucht
wow
dann kann es hier noch Butter rein hier
rein ja magst du
für deine linke Hand dass du den das
Töpfchen halten kannst
und wir machen ein bisschen Paprika rein
kein Problem
ja das stimmt ich habe dir die rechte
Hand für die Linke gegeben das ist der
winke Handschuhe damit man nur dann
sieht von wem er ist
das riecht und wirkt sehr lecker und das
ist das eigene Chiliöl was wir sozusagen
jetzt machen ja könnte man denn einen
Shortcut nehmen und auch einfach schon
fertiges nehmen zum Beispiel von dir was
man jetzt hier hätte könnte man
natürlich auch aber
das ist so lecker dann gebt ihr einfach
den Joghurt auf so einen Teller
zack zack zack
[Musik]
gut aus
und würde sagen sehr tasty
rüber
also das Shepherd schon ganz ordentlich
ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor deinen
Homepage Chilis ich auch ja aber es ist
gut
und jetzt
machen wir direkt die Verkostung so
schnell
danke schön
aber
wir hatten
Joghurt noch hat und dann ist man direkt
eine Abkühlung dahinter Shepherd aber
schon ganz ordentlich für Leute die echt
nicht gerne Schaf ist
eine ohrenschärfe hä achtung hier steht
jetzt echt viele Leute wer kennt die
ohrenschärfe 1 2 wer kennt die
ohrenschärfe nicht eins zwei drei vier
fünf Anna
ja übel
wir legen eins in die Mitte wir überlebt
gewinnt
[Musik]
sehr lecker
das ist einfach nur eine Vorspeise ist
aber für mich wäre das einfach so
ich brauche doch nichts anderes
Joghurt Chiliöl Brot
der dritte Trend ist finde ich bisschen
gefährlich
because man muss zur Dose nehmen und die
oben aufschneiden und das finde ich
tatsächlich weil die halt echt rasiert
klingen scharf sind bisschen gefährlich
finde ich auch sollten Kinder nicht
nachmachen wir haben es jetzt hier
fachmännisch Fachfrau ist aufschneiden
lassen aber sehr gefährlich bitte
aufpassen
jetzt kommt ein Trend das wird eine
Kerze die du essen kannst weil es eine
butterkerze ist und das finden wir
komisch bisschen auch komisch stell mal
vor du kommst immer nach Hause und dann
hat er so eine butterkerze auf dem Tisch
stehen und sagen ja okay wir probieren
ja Leute in der Sterne Gastro machen ja
hast du nicht so einen Stern
das heißt
dann haben wir hier Butter die schmilzt
und da gehen wir einfach noch Kräuter
rein
kannst du die ätherischen Öle das
erinnert mich immer noch zu Hause so
und das Schmelzen war jetzt hier einfach
kurz und lassen die Kräuter in der
Butter ziehen
[Musik]
und dann schmelzen die sich so da rein
also nicht klein machen du lässt die
groß damit sich die richtigen Aromen
alle entfalten genau und dann sieben was
durch da rein zack fertig genau
am besten jetzt schon mit bisschen
Butter an am Boden
dann stellen wir es kühl und in der
Zwischenzeit schmilzt der Rest
jetzt
halten
jetzt Thomas kurz ins Gefrierfach dann
wird es schnell fest und dann gießen wir
den Rest auf dann hält er doch
schon fast da
aber für den Docht reichts
sicher dass wir den jetzt schon
reinmachen ja wenn man Halter haben auch
ja weil weißt du eigentlich klebt man
denn doch unten hin damit er gleich
nicht schwimmt wenn die Flüssigkeit
kommt aber hätten wir nicht erst
Flüssigkeit reinmachen können dann das
Ding nach unten drücken und das dann so
halten lassen wir werden Halter haben
das kann dann sein dass er in der Mitte
anhält und das kannst du dann nicht mehr
kontrollieren
eigentlich mit so
deswegen hat man hier diese ganzen doch
Dinge und hier diese doch Kleber und
diese dort Kleber nimmst du eigentlich
und klebst du auf den Boden des Gefäßes
dann sind doch drauf dann hält der egal
wie viel Kerzenwachs da reinkommt aber
da das Ding ist nicht Lebensmittel
geeignet ist habe ich gedacht lass mich
lieber weg und kleben den doch lieber
mit der Butter an den Boden
und falls ihr auch bei Rituals anfangen
wollt schreibt uns einfach gerne in die
Kommentare wir bilden auch aus
so sieht's jetzt aus hat jetzt auch
nicht so lange gedauert
wird die Butter schneller kalt aber
einfrieren sollte es jetzt auch
natürlich okay jetzt ganz vorsichtig ihr
könnt jetzt auch am Rand aufschneiden
aber Gesundheit
unsere Kerze
die Molke ich finde tatsächlich die Idee
ist cool aber ich finde dass es eben mit
diesem aufgebauten Dose ist finde ich
nicht so cool vielleicht habt ihr eine
Idee was man stattdessen nehmen kann man
kann ja auch vielleicht so ein
Kunststoffbecher nehmen ist auch nicht
so nachhaltig aber sicherer als das oder
Silikon
Silikonformen kerzenformen wenn man
sowieso Förmchen hat genau also Dose ist
ein bisschen dangerous ja das z.B ist
jetzt auch schon schwieriger zu ziehen
in der etwas dickeren Dienstleister
ich habe auch schon probiert anzuwärmen
mit den Händen aber
dann wäre ich das gleich da
aber jetzt kommen wir probieren
auch bei normalen Kerzen
weil es dann zu hoch braucht
und der Sinn dahinter soll er jetzt sein
du hast jetzt quasi ein Frühstücksbuffet
oder Abendessen
wir wollen das Dennis das auch sieht
okay komm Dennis
[Musik]
also komm mal zwischen uns wegen
Mikrofon und allem das ist Dennis kennt
ihr ja schon
und zwar haben Freddie und nicht
tiktok transke das denn
gedacht das ist eigentlich ganz cool
wäre das sonst leider erst beim letzten
Trend eingefallen
diesen Trend testet und zwar ist es
Butter
in Form einer Kerze
und das Besondere daran soll sein dass
man die halt so anzündet dann sieht es
romantisch und hübsch aus und dann
nimmst du Brot dann gibst du das so rein
ist auch bisschen flasert mit Salbei und
Rosmarin okay was macht das mit dir wenn
du das siehst ist das so eine Sterne
Lokal Vorspeisen Ding wenn man so jetzt
Talk ich habe meinen drei Sterne
Restaurant auch so eine Kerze stehen
gehabt zum Essen
die war aber aus Schweineschmalz ist
natürlich jetzt ein bisschen kritisch
aber die ist dann so 3-4-gänge vorher
auf dem Tisch gestellt worden und
angezündet worden kommentarlos und dann
haben sie gesagt so jetzt kannst du das
Essen und das ganz Restaurant
Valentinstag schon rum ne ja leider
nichts
der 19 Februar ich war vorgestern bei
Let's Dance in der ersten Sendung
super peinlich auch wenn man rausfliegen
würde in der ersten Sendung wäre das
peinlich Manometer aber das nochmal
nachschauen wollt könnt ihr es bei RTL
plus nachschauen aber ansonsten immer
live mitschauen wenn man dann für mich
anrufen kann ne weil die zwei Jungs sind
die wählen sich die Finger bunt
gerade muss man aber auch ehrlich sagen
dass RTL mich und mein Team mit deinen
Buchstaben auf dem Bauch gepinsel
komplett rausgeschnitten hat weil er uns
halt so Mühe gegeben Arsch aufgerissen
das rein zu schmuggeln die Farbe
angesagt aber ich wollte naja
Herr Sternekoch warum schmilzt die
Butter nicht dauert ne
ganz oben deswegen quasi drei vier Gänge
vorher ne das ist auf jeden Fall das wo
man sich Zeit nehmen kann ne kann man
das beschleunigen indem man das tun
genau
drei vier Gänge später
verrückt dass man so eine Kerze jetzt
dippt
aber das ist cool
wie lange war die jetzt im Kühlschrank
oder wie lange steht die jetzt schon
draußen
zwei Minuten zwei Minuten
abnehmen weil man sieht jetzt unten die
Molke also wenn oder einfach mit
Butterschmalz
nach Hause ne von Let's Dance und Murat
hat gekauft
soweit man dann sobald man dann mal ein
bisschen älter wird mit dem butterkerzen
auf den Kuchen wird dann aber ein
bisschen komplexer nur sollte man auch
irgendwann sagen wenn es dann doch keine
Butter bei Kerze mehr war nicht dass man
aus Versehen echte Kerzen ne weil man
dann denkt also das waren unsere drei
Trends die wir ausprobiert haben ich
finde es eigentlich ziemlich cool
wenn man die Kerze nicht einfriert wenn
man sie vorher ein bisschen vorher raus
nimmt ne ja vielen Dank Freddy auch dass
ich zu Gast bei dir sein durfte danke
für die ganzen Fragen eine letzte Frage
habt ihr Phantom Vibration Handy
kein Stress dafür bin ich da
alles gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]